john matsey is the ceo of parlour we're
happy to have him on the show tonight
john thanks so much for coming on i have
to start at the end
and ask you if it since you built this
application
as a kind of safe space for freedom of
speech
did you ever imagine that amazon web
services
could or would shut you down in an
instant
thank you for having me on um i've
theorized about it
you know we've definitely theorized
about it you should never think it'll
happen
though right you you know and uh what's
really interesting
is uh that they all did it on the same
day those three
without any prior warning we woke up on
friday thinking
business well not never business as
usual parlor but at least as close to
usual as possible we were number one in
the app store
we you know we had seven million almost
seven million unique people
on the app that day um and we get a
notice you know you're in violation of
our terms one after another but we found
out first
in some cases not from the companies but
from buzzfeed
you know we didn't get a notice from
google we read it online
in the news first and uh that is
shocking
and then after they set that example you
know
we get an email after email you know
it's almost like
you you were just waiting who's gonna be
next dumping us
everybody the last thing we have right
now is email and i bet you within 24
hours our email will be shut off too
i just got to ask you because i can't
because i think this is a referendum on
american society and where we are
and where we're going the left used to
stand up for civil liberties
the famously moderate joe manchin
approves of this apart from glenn
greenwald and michael tracy god bless
them both
i haven't seen any liberals stand up to
say wow this is really scary have you
um i i'm not sure i mean i i've seen a
lot of people say that this is scary but
i've also seen a lot of people who are
participating in the five minutes of
hate
and kind of egging it on and cheering
and it's disgusting
people threatening my life i can't go
home tonight
so there's this is really a lot you know
this is not just you know our civil
liberties they can shut down a billion
dollar company half a billion to a
billion dollar company that's what we
were getting valuations at
overnight are you going to be back up
soon uh we will be back up eventually
because we're not gonna give up
uh but it soon is difficult you know
i thought immediately oh no problem
we'll call up a new vendor
right we call up the vendor we're all
good to go and then right at the last
second sorry somebody said something we
can't host dubai
and it's been that one after another
ever since then
right at the last minute they just they
just bail so
we're gonna do it we're gonna be back
online one day
and hopefully soon as soon as possible
but
um this is a real challenge we have to
build our own infrastructure our own
everything in order to do it pirate
radio
digital pirate radio dark web i hope so
yeah i hope we're out of time i hope
john you'll come back
you will come back with a list of every
corporate coward
who bowed to pressure to silence you and
seven million other people
on parlor you can bet i will and no
almost 20 million people now
almost 20 million and yes i will
yeah i i won't forget this day great to
see you john thank you
thank you well